Config or configuration management. If
we go by the definition then we can say
that config management is the systematic
approach to organize or store or access
or basically maintaining all the
settings. This is the key word here. All
the settings of our backend app. So you
can think of this as a DNA of your
application. It decides how your code
runs in different different
environments. When you say configuration
management to most people then the first
impression that we get the first idea
that hits our mind is storing some kind
of database passwords the secure
connection URL of our database or things
like secure authentication keys secret
keys for your JWT secrets etc etc or any
API keys of external services like say
your email delivery service storing API
keys for external services like that.
Those are the things that comes to our
mind whenever we talk about config
management. But thinking like that
misses a lot of scope in configuration
management because that's like saying a
car is just about the engine. Engine is
definitely the most important part of a
car but you're still missing out the 90%
of the other features of a car. So
similarly configuration management it it
has a lot of other things starting from
how your application starts up, how it
connects to external services, how it
behaves depending on different different
environments, what does it log, whether
it logs or not and where it logs and
where does it send all the details about
your metrics, the performance metrics,
your business metrics and things like
which features are we enabling for this
version of the deployment and which
features are going to be disabled and
for which users we are enabling which
features etc. There is a lot of scope
for config management and in this video
I want to touch upon what are the
different things we care about what are
the different things we think about
whenever we talk about config management
it's not just limited to your database
URL or your secret keys it affects a lot
of behaviors important behaviors of your
backend application so definitely an
important topic to discuss here so let's
say you are building an e-commerce
platform. You're building an e-commerce
platform and if you are working on the
back end of an e-commerce platform then
your configuration might include some of
the things like what are the timeout
details, what is the host, what is the
port, what is the username, what is the
password etc etc all the connection
details of our database. It might also
have your payment processor API keys.
Let's say you are using stripe then you
might have your stripe API keys there.
Also your feature flags. What are the
feature flags that we are enabling for
this deployment and what are the
features that we are keeping disabled
for this deployment. And these feature
flags let's say they control we built a
new checkout flow in our e-commerce
platform and using a particular feature
flag we can control that whether we are
still using the old checkout flow or we
are using the new checkout flow and we
can also conditionally enable the new
checkout flow for some users and the old
checkout flow for some other users. So
we use feature flags for these kinds of
instances. You might also have
performance tuning parameters like what
are we keeping our connection pool size
connection pool that we use for our
database connections. Also security
settings like what is session timeouts
whether it is 30 seconds 60 seconds and
we can also store things like business
rules. Business rules for an e-commerce.
It might contain things like what is the
maximum amount of order for a user and
each of these different configuration
that we talked about starting from
database connection details to payment
processor API keys to feature flags to
performance tuning parameters and
security sessions security settings like
session timeout settings and also
business tools. All these different
different configurations have different
different characteristics. Some of them
are sensitive. Some of them are supposed
to be kept in secret. We are not
supposed to leak them and they might
cause a lot of damage. They might cause
a lot of loss. And some of them are not
secretive but they impact they control
how our application behaves while it is
running. Also some of them might change
frequently and some of them let's say
they change once a month or once a
quarter etc. And some of the
configurations may stay the same for all
our environments in our development
environment in our staging environment
and in our production environment and
some of the configs they'll be different
depending on which environment that we
are running our application. In all of
this there is one challenge which is
distributed systems. Most of our modern
applications all our modern backends
they don't run in isolation anymore.
Most of them are now part of a complex
distributed system. A system consisting
of multiple services databases caches
like radius etc or message cues or third
party integrations or authentication or
emails and a lot of things. And all
these different different integration
points where we are connecting a
separate service to our main back end.
They all require configuration. Your
back end obviously it needs to know how
to connect to these services. But on top
of that, it also needs to know how to
handle failures, how to optimize
performance and how to maintain security
depending on different environment,
depending on different settings and
depending on different configs that we
can control from different different
sources that we will soon talk about.
And this is the reason the reason that
most of our modern backends they run on
distributed systems. This is why
configuration management becomes an
important part of your application. And
if you don't have a systematic approach,
if you don't have a dedicated pipeline,
if you don't have a dedicated strategy
to manage your config, you will end up
with what we call as configuration
chaos. Configuration chaos basically
means that instead of controlling some
configs from a centralized point, you
have hard-coded values scattered
throughout your codebase. And you also
have inconsistent behavior across
different different environments. You
also have security vulnerabilities from
exposed secrets and debugging your
application becomes a nightmare because
you cannot really reproduce these issues
because you don't have a centralized way
of managing your config. So you don't
really know what exactly happened and
what particular config caused a
particular issue, what particular config
caused a particular break in production.
The stakes are pretty high for backend
engineers these days since they handle
the core business logic and data is
pretty much the most important part of
any platform any enterprise. So if you
think about it, a misconfigured front
end, it might show let's say a wrong
feature, a wrong dialogue which it's
it's not supposed to show or it might
redirect to a wrong route. But a
misconfigured backend, it can cause a
lot of damage. It can expose customer
data. It can process payments
incorrectly or it can bring down your
entire platform if some important part
of it is affected by it. Since backend
systems run in diverse environments,
different cloud providers, different
onremises servers and containers and
serverless functions and edge functions
and all have their own requirement of
different different configurations.
Since we are talking about cloud
providers, let me tell you a little bit
about the sponsor of this video which is
Savala, a platform as a service provider
and you can deploy your applications,
your databases and your object storage,
your deployment pipelines and you name
it. If your team is paying per seat
pricing in other platform as a service
providers for your hosting needs, you
are literally throwing your money away.
I'll show you how you can save $300
per month while actually getting a
better infrastructure and support. So
this is the math. If we take a look at
this platforms like Render, they charge
around $29
per month. And if let's say we talk
about Railway, they charge around $20
per month. and platforms like Netifi,
they want $19 per team member. So if you
are a 5% dev team, that's around $145
to $290 monthly just for the privilege
of collaboration. And let's say your
team is doubled. You have now 10
developers. Now you're looking at
monthly $290 to $580 monthly just for
the seat fees. You have other cloud
hosting fees. Just for the seed fees,
you are paying almost $500 per month
before you even deploy a single app. If
you can feel the frustration, then you
can definitely check out Seala. They
don't have any seatbased pricing. Seala
is basically a Kinsta product. Kinsta,
these guys have been around for a long
time. They are one of the most famous
hosting platforms when we are talking
about WordPress. And seala is their
latest offering. Since they already had
the infrastructure for all their hosting
needs, they have created this product
called seala. And the interesting thing
about this platform is they don't have
any seedbased pricing. Absolutely zero.
Your entire team gets full access
whether you have two developers or 200.
But just because your costs have come
down, do not assume that you are going
to get lesser quality. Seala uses GCP
behind the scenes and the premier tier
networking of GCP and it runs Kubernetes
behind the scenes with 25 data centers
around the world with 99% SLA. They also
have an integrated cloudflare offering
which has around 260 plus points of
presence around the world offering you
things like edge CDN DOS protection and
edge caching global load balancing and a
lot of things that cloudfl natively
brings. You get enterprise reliability
without paying for the enterprisegrade
pricing. Sealasa supports more than 20
programming languages through Nyx packs
which is more resource efficient than
traditional build packs. You get
automatic deployments using GitHub,
GitLab, Bitbucket, whatever version
control system that you are using in
your team and also zero downtime
Kubernetes health checks throughout your
applications. You get features like
hibernation pause for your development
environments and horizontal scaling for
all your production traffic spikes. But
unlike most platforms, Seala has a human
monitoring system. Their support team
actually monitors your deployments. If
you are facing a lot of errors and
facing a lot of challenges in your
deployments, they reach out to you to
help you out and help your team out.
That's not something you'll see in a lot
of platforms. They also have a lot of
compliance checks. You have sock 2, you
have ISO, GDPR, CCPA, does not matter
what your compliance needs are, they're
already there. So if that sounds
interesting to you, check out Savala and
you'll get $50 credits to try out
different applications, database
hosting, object storage, whatever your
needs are. You can calculate your team's
current seatbased cost and see how much
you'll save as compared to other
platforms. Your CFO will definitely love
the budget relief and your developers
will love the simplicity of the
platform. So what are the different
types of configuration that we are
talking about here? Because not all
configurations are created equal and
understanding the different types of
configuration data is very important for
choosing the storage mechanism, the
security measures and the access
patterns, who can access and what
environments a particular configures
should be accessible. So let's talk
about what are the different types of
configuration, what do they look like,
where do they actually get used. The
first one is our most common kind of
config which is the application
settings. Application settings is the
most common kind of config that you will
see in most backend apps and this
basically includes our log level and
things like our port which port the
backend application is going to run on
our connection pool size our timeout
values. timeout values like if you have
an HTTP request then how long the server
should wait for the request to get
completed. So if you set a timeout value
for 60 seconds and let's say you
initiate a request which generates an AI
image, your back end generates an AI
image and sends it back to your front
end in base 64 format and the AI image
generation takes let's say around on
average 80 seconds. So if your server
timeout is 60 seconds then your request
is going to get dropped. you will get a
status code of 504 timeout status.
Similarly, log level in usually when we
are developing our application on
development environment, we set the log
level to debug so that we can actually
see and we can actually differentiate
between different different logs when we
are creating the application when the
application is running on our local
environment. And when we go to
production then we change the log level
to info so that we don't clutter a lot
of logs in our valuable production logs.
Same port usually we run our back end
app in local 8080 and depending on your
production setup whether you are using
VPS or Kubernetes you might have
different different ports. Same way
connection pool size for our database
connections or our database operations.
Most backend apps use this technique
called connection pooling. Connection
pooling helps us optimize database
connections. So we can also configure
what is the maximum connection pool size
that we want to have. So these are some
of the common application level settings
that you will see in pretty much all the
different kinds of backends. Next up,
what do we have? Second, we have
database. Database config. Now, database
config basically includes all the
details your application needs to
connect to your database. This will
include the host where your database is
running on, the port of your database,
the username of your database, the
password and the name of your database.
All these different different parameters
combined you can create a connection URL
and that URL can be used when your
application is running to connect to
your database. It might also have other
parameters things like timeouts how long
your database query should run for
before it times out. Moving on the third
type of config that we can have is
external services. Now external services
can be a lot of different types. If you
are using emails then you might have an
email provider like Mailchimp or
something model like resend. Does not
matter what provider that you use.
You'll most probably have some kind of
API key in your config that you will
need to send the emails to initiate the
client. Similarly, if you are using any
kind of payment processor, let's say
Stripe, then you might also have a
Stripe API key. Or if you are using for
authentication, if you are using
something like clerk, then you'll also
have a clerk API key. So all these
different different services that we
call as external services, they also
have their own configuration needs and
you'll also need to cater to that. Then
the next type we have is feature flags.
Feature flags. Feature flags exist so
that we can dynamically enable or
disable particular features of our
application. So as earlier I gave an
example you are building an e-commerce
platform and you have an checkout flow.
You have a checkout flow where we have
all the order details here and here
there's the payment details and proceed
to payment. Something like this. And now
you're building a new checkout flow. And
for that you are using a different API
and you don't want to roll out this new
checkout flow for all your users. You
want to do some kind of AB testing with
it. You want to only enable this feature
for a particular segment of your user
depending on the location of the users.
You let's say you only want to enable
this feature for people who are from US
and you want to keep it disabled for
people who are from India. If you have
requirements like that, we use feature
flags for dynamically enabling or
disabling features in our application.
So feature flags also need some kind of
config management. So that's the fourth
category. Apart from that we also have
other types things like let's say infra
config all your devops related configs
and let's say your security config
your JWT secret your session secret
anything related to security that your
application is impacted from then we
also have performance tuning performance
tuning parameters so if your back end is
built with something like go or go line
then you can set different different
environment variables like the maximum
number of CPUs etc etc then also we have
business rules different logic related
rules that you want to enforce on
application level but you want to
centralize that config so that's when we
use business rule related config
management so that's pretty much all
about different types of conflict that
you will face on your day-to-day life as
a backend engineer the second important
thing is different sources of config
basically the storage of configs. If we
have all these diverse needs of config
management then definitely we'll also
need to think about the storing of the
configs and the where do you and where
you store your configurations it depends
on a lot of parameters depending on
security depending on speed and your
environment. When we're talking about
storage of configurations, then the most
common kind that I have seen and most
people probably have seen is the
environment variables. And if you have
worked with backends before, then envend
apps. is mostly common among NodeJS apps
but we also have support for them in
Python Golang does not matter what
programming language that you're
creating your backends in. This is the
most common place where we store our
configurations. If we are running in our
local environments then we have a file
called env. We use any library a library
called env is very famous which
basically takes all your environment
variables from env and it loads it in
your operating systems environment. So
this is basically a feature provided by
your operating systems. This is not
something you build but we have
libraries which take these values from
files and load it in our environment
instead of us doing it manually with
export. Similarly, if you're not in a
local environment, let's say you are
deploying in some kind of containerized
environment using Kubernetes etc etc. So
those technologies also have support for
loading your environment variables while
they are deploying your application. So
this is the workflow that happens when
you deploy it in a cloud provider using
environment variables. The deployment
triggers at a particular stage it
fetches all your environment variables
from any kind of service let's say from
vault which is from hashiorp or
something like this parameter store or
azure or google secret manager any cloud
provider which gives this feature of
secrets management it fetches for it
fetches from all these cloud providers
and it loads that in your environment.
And then when your application starts,
it takes those environment variables and
it functions whatever way it is supposed
to function. That is the most common
storage we have for our configurations.
The second kind is files. Now in files
we have different different formats. We
store configurations either in JSON but
these days YAML is more famous for
storing configurations. One of the major
disadvantages of using JSON is you
cannot add comments. JSON does not have
support for comments. That's why most
people will use YAML. There you can add
your configuration and you can also add
different different comments so that
it's easier for your team to share
knowledge. We also have a newer standard
which is toml file. This is also pretty
heavily used for managing
configurations. So if we were to take a
look at a real world codebase. So this
is some okay this is an example of AIA.
This is a authentication provider
technology. This is a Golang
application. As you can see this have
all these go files. So here you can see
we have a configuration.yamel file and
there are different different values. We
have server we have log level. debug,
storage, our notification related
details, identity related details, our
regulations, session related details and
all these things all of them are stored
in a single YAML file. And if you were
to search for config then in the results
you can see we have config.yamel in a
lot of different different places. This
is from incubator answer is also another
famous open source reposit from Apache
and you can see they also have some
fixed configurations for app settings
that we just talked about application
related settings like your which port
your server should run on the databases
for local environments they are using
SQLite and the swagger UI config UI
config. So storing your configurations
in a YAML file is pretty common in most
of the opensource repositories. Moving
on, we also have evalu.
But we also have dedicated tools like
console or etc. these cloudnative tools.
We also have access to them. Depending
on your use case, you can use any of
them. Key value stores are pretty
lightweight and pretty simple to make
use of as compared to other complicated
and hierarchical data structures for
config management. This acts mostly like
your environment variables. Then we also
have dedicated cloud providers cloud
here majorly we have hashore vault. Then
we have AWS parameter store Azure key
wault all these different different
providers. If let's say we take a look
at Aship or Walt, you can explore all
these different different services which
are dedicated for config management your
secrets management that most companies
use because we have deployment set up in
a distributed manner. We have
Kubernetes, we have autoscaling and we
also sometimes make use of different
different cloud providers at the same
time for our scaling needs. So having
our all our configurations in a
centralized manner in a tool something
like hashikov's vault which already is
ready for all these different different
environments. They already have
dedicated support. They already have
dedicated docs and everything to make
the integration as easy as possible.
Using a external provider makes a lot of
sense if you are running a big user
traffic in production. But most of the
time we also make use of hybrid
strategies. Let's say we have a file
where we load all our configs and
construct a runtime application
settings. And when we are in this
loading phase, we might fetch our
configs from different different places.
In the first priority, we might fetch
from AWS parameter store. Then we might
also have a config. DAML. Then we might
also have some environment variables. So
we can predecide that which of these
should have the higher priority. And
depending on the environment we can load
those configs conditionally depending on
the priority and the environment. So
that's all about different different
stoages for storing our configs. Now one
question we have is why do we have
different different configs depending on
the environment that we are running on.
And the answer to that is pretty simple
because each environment has a setup
priorities that the other environment
does not need or it should not have. For
example, if we are running in a dev
environment, whether it is your local in
a dev environment, let's say in your
local environment, you are running on
local host, then our number one priority
is developer productivity and our
debugging capabilities. so that we can
work faster and we can catch issues
faster. Similarly, if we are running in
a test environment, we trigger a GitHub
action and it prepares some kind of
testing environment where we can run
different different integration testings
or unit testing or whatever testing
setup that you have. Then in that kind
of environment, our number one priority
is automated validation and quality
assurance. Similarly, staging
environment. Staging environment is
basically a hosted version of our
application that is as that works and
functions as similar to our production
environment as possible so that we have
a clear idea what our production
environment is going to work like and we
can make changes fix issues and debug
issues accordingly. So that is the
priority of the staging environment.
Similarly the last one in our production
environment the number one priority is
reliability and security and
performance. So we create our configs
keeping these priorities in mind and
that is the reason our configs are
loaded in different ways. They are
stored in different ways and they are
different in their values depending on
which environment that we are running in
the application code. Of course, it
remains the same, but depending on the
config, the behavior of our application
changes and that is exactly what we
want. Without changing the code of our
application, which we might have to do
if we are hard- coding things, but since
we are centralizing our config
management, we will never have to touch
our application code. We can make
changes in our config and that will
reflect in the behavior of our
application. So if we take an example of
our database pool size in your
development environment when you are
running in your local host you can set
your pool size max pool size for 10 and
it mostly works fine while you are
testing your application while you are
developing your application you don't
really face any issues because local
host these days most people have
high-end devices and it can it has a lot
capacity for these kinds of things. But
on production, you have set the
connection pool size to 50 because you
have to cater to a large user base and
you might get traffic spikes in
different different times. So you have
to be prepared for that. So you have set
a higher database pool size in your
production environment. Similarly, in
your staging environment, you have set
the pool size to two because even though
in staging environment, our number one
priority is to mirror the functionality
and the capabilities of our production
environment as much as possible so that
we can catch issues earlier. We can
understand our production system better.
But running a similar system which
functions exactly like our production
systems will cost the same amount when
it comes to our cloud costs and that's
not something a lot of teams want. We
want to save as much money as possible
when we are talking about cloud costs.
So in our development environment our
another set of priority is minimizing
our cloud costs. So database pool size
since we already know that a staging
environment is usually is used by our
developers or our testers. So we can
take some decisions like keeping our
database pool size to minimum and we can
accommodate some kind of delay there but
we'll save a lot of money in our cloud
costs. And the last thing that we have
to talk about when we are talking about
config management is security. These are
pretty obvious points, but just for the
sake of covering all the scope, I'll
mention these. Never hardcode your
secrets. If you have secrets like your
production database URL, the API key of
your clerk service or your email
delivery service or your payment
processing service, you should never
hardcode those secrets in your codebase,
right? It's pretty obvious. I don't even
have to explain why you should not.
Second thing is if it's possible always
try to go for a cloud secrets management
service something like as I showed
earlier hashikorp vault or AWS parameter
store or Azure key wault or Google
secret manager. It's always a good idea
to overengineer when it comes to
security of your backend application.
These services they already handle
things like encrypting all your configs
when they are stored in their storage.
It does not matter where they store your
config but whenever they store it they
encrypt it and then they store it
somewhere in any kind of database or any
kind of storage. Similarly, when they
are in transition, when you make an API
call and you fetch all the configs, they
send you the encrypted one and with your
private key which is stored in your
infra or your GitHub action or your
repository secret or your Kubernetes
environment there they are decoded and
then you use them. So they are encrypted
when they are stored and they are also
encrypted when they are transferred from
one point to another when you are
fetching them. Now these are essential
security features and when you use a
cloud provider like a vault or as
parameter store all these things are
already taken care of and you don't have
to think about these. Third thing is
access control. If you have a fairly
large developers team you should take
some time to strategize who should have
access to all your configs following the
rule of least privilege. Developers who
are working on front end, they should
only have access to all the configs that
they need for functioning things like
the API URL of the back end and
different different API keys for front-
end integrations etc. And if you have
backend engineer, they should only have
access to your databases, your radius
instance, your elastic search, etc.,
etc. But something like configs for
accessing your cloud instances, your EC2
instances only your DevOps team should
have access to those. So following the
least privilege principle, you should
strategize your access control and you
should also have things like rotation
periodically. You should rotate all your
configs, all your API key secrets, all
your JWT secrets and things like these
so that they are not very prone to
leakage. And the last thing that I want
to mention here is validation. Most of
the times that I have personally seen,
we don't always validate our environment
variables or whatever source our configs
are coming from. Let's say if we are
using env
we load all the variables in our
environment and we just access it using
process env dot whatever the name of the
variable is. But one of the key
strategies that can help decrease a lot
of headache is when you are loading your
config which is usually the start before
your application starts after it is
deployed you should validate all the
configs does not matter whatever source
they are coming from if they are coming
from they are coming from AWS parameter
store if they are coming from a file
let's say config.l ML file always
validate them using a proper validation
library. If you have a TypeScript back
end then you can use ZOD. If you have
Go, you can use Go validator playground
library, any kind of validation library
that your programming language, your
framework offers and properly validate
all the variables depending on which
ones are mandatory to provide, which
ones are optional and you're setting the
default in your application code and
thinking about all these different
scenarios. Always validate your
configurations. I have learned this the
hard way. It can cause a lot of damage.
It can cause a lot of confusion in your
production environment because it's not
very easy to spot that you have a
mandatory environment variable
requirement but you were not able to
provide it and now your production
system is either breaking or behaving in
a strange way because it does not have
access to a particular environment
variable. If you were to take one thing
from this video, this is the most
important part. Always validate your
conflicts. Does not matter where they
are coming from. on a smile. The